joining us now the reigning nfl coach
of the year second year brown's head
coach kevin stefanski how do you like
that
that that title coach of the year what
do you think about
i'm more what have you done for me
lately mike so you won
a year that's what you did now you get
you got to earn it every day so
i'm past that where's the trophy
i don't think i've received it yet i
think it's coming in the mail so i
haven't gotten it yet
the family's got i mean look it
validates the decision you're in
minnesota forever
you you have other opportunities over
the years you pick this job
the fact that it worked to the point and
only one team wins the super bowl the
fact that it worked to the point where
you get that kind of recognition
it has to make you feel good about the
decision you made doesn't it
it does mike i think it speaks more to
this coaching staff and i really believe
that i we set out to hire
a really good coaching staff and then i
think we have men and women here that
put them
put the team first so i'm really proud
of that fact
and if that award shines light on on our
staff then i'm then i'm happy about that
you know one of the most fascinating
stories of the 2020 season as the
pandemic impact of the game the fact
that you were home
watching a playoff win the first playoff
win in the history of the reconstituted
cleveland browns coming against the
archrival steelers
what was that three hours like for you
i don't recommend it it was uh it was
excruciating
it really was i think as a coach as a
play caller
you have so much control and you're
making decisions
and you're right in the nitty-gritty of
it all and then
to stand there i didn't sit to stand
there and watch your team
uh perform number one that was surreal
just not being there
and then to see how they performed in
that game especially early as as we all
watched it uh at home
uh you know i was so proud of those guys
and
uh you know i really i expected listen
you go into every game you're expecting
to win but
i wasn't surprised that guys were ready
to play that's just what they've done
all season long
and i know how superstitious we all are
when it comes to sports what did the
thought even cross your mind and i'm
saying this half tongue in cheek
to go right back to where you were for
the next round of the playoffs did not
emerge from your basement yeah well
considering we lost that game that
sounds like a good idea
but yeah i told the guys that bad news
is i was coming back to work that next
week
how much of the playoffs do you watch
after
your team exits live
quite a bit i think it's it's really
important as coaches that we're
constantly looking at what other people
are doing and uh you know
we joke about we don't mind stealing uh
ideas from from the collegiate level
from the pro level so
i think it helps us in terms of
offensively defensively
what are other people doing how are they
doing it and then helps inspire you as
you're putting together your offense so
any any game that we're not playing and
i love to watch i mean i think about
by weekend uh you know i probably should
be out doing something you know
uh productive but instead i like to sit
there and
buzz around the league like the like
everybody else does
and see what people are doing because we
talk about
constantly trying to tweak what we're
doing and i think one way to do that is
to really hone in and study what other
teams are doing
you know i heard from another head coach
at the time that you had to be home for
that playoff game and this is a guy
with with no dog in the fight no staking
it whatsoever
he just thought it wasn't right in this
day and age that we now
occupy where people are able to
virtually do anything and everything and
tony romo worked the game from home mike
tarico worked a game from home
why can't there be something created
to allow you to be involved from home
did that conversation come up at all
with the league
in the days leading up to the steelers
game they were very clear with what the
rules were mike i hope that no one's
ever in a situation like that
in the future where that would even be a
possibility
i think you're right i think you could
pull it off certainly from a
technological standpoint uh but i think
then there'd be concerns about what
what technology is at your fingertips
from your home that that you wouldn't
necessarily have in the coaches booth
because
as as i think a lot of your uh you know
audience knows when you're in that
coaches booth on the road
no cell phones are out you can't have
access to internet so it's very
much a uh a sterile environment and the
league wants to make sure of that for
competitive reasons
now i know how i would be
if i had your job and i try to look for
the the things that are relatable to the
average human who constantly resides in
regret and second guessing
and i'd be obsessing over something from
this past
year that would have made a difference
is there one thing that you can't get
out of your head that if this would have
gone differently whether it was a call
a decision you made something bounce the
ball is there something that just keeps
eating i don't i hate to bring up
but i'm curious is there something that
is just gnawing at you
that you think if this had gone
differently we'd have made it to the
next level
yeah i mean for me it's easy it's that
last game
and i think any time you come up short
you're constantly asking yourself what
could i have done differently how could
i put the players in a better position
so i go right back to that last playoff
game which i've watched many many times
since since that
game ended and i'll continue to do that
and and i want to be really really hard
on myself
because as the play caller ultimately
it's my job to put our guys in position
to succeed
and we fell short so i take that to
heart i've watched that game many times
and
and i've said this before i i really
appreciate that we have a coaching staff
here
where we can ask each other hard
questions we can say what would have
been a better
call here what would have been a better
play design here and those type of
things and that's really
i've said it before but that's the fuel
for my off season for
our offseason as an organization is is
we felt we fell short we came up short
and and we have to own that and then we
got to use that as fuel
as we go forward one of the things i've
noticed about your style in one year on
the job you do seem to be the ultimate
harry s truman buck stops here coach
you never call out anyone publicly you
take full blame for everything that
happens even maybe if it isn't your
fault
i assume that at some point
we've we pivot to accountability for
individuals but that all happens behind
closed doors and out of the eyes and
ears of the media
uh well first of all i share a birthday
with harry truman wow
yeah i think so
mike i think listen accountability is a
is a major part of how we operate around
here it's part of our identity
uh being accountable so that's me to the
players the players to me our coaches to
me
me to our coaches so that's something
that we are always doing now does it
play out in the media no
often times it doesn't but if you don't
have that piece you really have nothing
to stand on
who'd you learn that from because really
every coach does it differently and
based on only one year i would say that
that you have stuck to that
it's my fault it's my fault it's my
fault as well as anyone i've seen
well i hope i'm not saying it too much
those things are wrong
okay if you're losing it's a problem but
i mean it is the truth i mean it's my
job
you know win loser draw we're going to
win together we're going to lose
together but
i'm the one that's going to answer to it
i want our players and coaches
to both play fearlessly coach fearlessly
because they know ultimately that we're
getting judged together but
i'll be out in front when i and i've
said this before and and i
you know where did i learn this i don't
know mike but and you see
people do this all the time but i'm very
comfortable leading out in front
and i'm extremely comfortable leading
from behind and i know when it's time to
go backstage and let somebody else have
that spotlight
now if i were to pinpoint specific
moments from the chiefs game
that i would want to go back and and
fix or do over or whatever the richard
higgins fumble that goes into the end
zone and out of the end zone
let me get your thoughts on that rule
i i've always hated it
and you have reason to hate it now
although i know from experience
sometimes a coach who was burned by a
bad rule doesn't want it to go away
until he gets to pay off on the other
side
how do you feel about that rule right
now yeah you know i was part of the
2009 uh nfc championship game
where the saints got the ball first in
overtime drove down kicked the field
goal and the game was over
and i think that was the impetus of
changing the rule where both teams
possess it
you know i had never really given a lot
of thought to that rule
and i just that was the rule and and
that's and we coached it
uh based on that rule because it is uh
it's really impactful when you fumble
i would just tell you it was an
unfortunate play uh
i i trust the league in making decisions
that are best for the game going forward
if that's something they want to
look at i'd support that if they don't
we'll continue to coach it
how we do uh it's it's a tough penalty
because it's such an exciting play
and it's so the guys want to score and
they get down there and they want to
reach the ball for the pylon and think
about
all the plays over the years uh where
that that's an indelible image
of of guys scoring touchdowns and big
games so
i understand the urge that guys have to
want to
do that but that penalty is just or
excuse me that uh
the enforcement of that rule is so
penalizing to the offense that you
really have to coach it
the way we do which is don't stick that
ball out unless it's fourth down but
that's very hard
uh for athletes and guys that are
competitive and want to score touchdowns
see that's the problem and that's where
the league needs to take a step back
and ask are we taking the incentive out
of having a memorable play i know for a
fact one of the reasons they still use
two sticks and 10 yards of chain is for
that two seconds
of the is it a first down or not when
they stretch it out they could do it
digitally but it wouldn't have that
drama
there's drama in the guy reaching the
football for the pylon i guess there's
more drama if we factor in the
possibilities if it comes out of his
hands and goes out of bounds in the end
zone
the other team gets the ball at the 20.
it's just never made sense to me
have you heard from talking to any other
people that there will actually be
reason and belief that they're going to
take a close look at it or is that just
what people say after a situation like
that happens
yeah i haven't heard anything mike you
know we got the owners meeting coming up
towards the end of the month
and the competition committee will get
together and maybe we'll hear some more
coming at it about that but again
i'm of the belief that you just tell us
what the rules are and we'll coach
accordingly
what do you think about the lowering the
helmet rule as it relates to the fact
that
calls and non-calls aren't subject to
replay review because
in that same moment we had that play out
where
replay review you looked at it while
there was lowering the helmet
and we we've had the argument in the
past about defenseless receivers should
those calls be subject to replay review
would you like to see replay expanded
for plays like that that can be so
impactful
if they're missed or if they're called
incorrectly
i think in general i'm of the opinion
less replay
than more i think as as our fans uh
prefer the game to to go and speed up
and not be stopping
every time you know those are really
tough plays mike when it comes to
lowering the helmet because
uh speaking from experience as a former
defensive back and and not a very good
one but
when you when you go to make a tackle
and your targeting may be great and that
player moves at the last split second
and now all of a sudden you have helmet
to helmet contact so it's just
it's really hard i mean you have running
backs that that lower their pads
as they come into the open field and now
their helmets are down so
it's it's very very difficult i think
first and foremost we should be talking
about the health and safety of our
players
uh so i to support anything that that
encourages
that uh aspect of it but uh
in general i'd tell you i would i prefer
less replay than more
speaking of player health and safety
what's your reaction when you see miles
garrett in his jurassic park
tank top playing basketball
my reaction is i think one of those nba
teams should sign him to a 10-day
contract
yeah he's a great athlete uh that
doesn't surprise me
seeing him move around i've he he knows
this i've told him this i've told all of
our players listen
you got to stay in shape you need to to
do some things that get your cardio
going
uh you got to do it safely and he he's
very very well
aware of that but i i do marvel at his
athleticism
so you didn't do like the chiefs did a
couple of years ago when we saw the
video of patrick mahomes playing
basketball when they told him no patrick
no more basketball
you're fine with guys doing within
reasonable limits what they need to do
to stay in shape
i think that's the key within reasonable
limits they know not to go in some
competitive game where they're going to
turn an ankle or catch an elbow or those
type of things but
if they're working on their body which
you know these guys that is their
lifeblood is is their body if they're if
they're looking to get more athletic and
quicker and stronger
i'm going to support that and within
reason
i know that the league has yet to tell
the teams what the salary cap will be
have they told you when they're going to
tell you what the salary cap will be
yeah i think it's got to come sooner
than later you know you got the
franchise tag
the deadline coming up you know to start
a free agency so
i'm in a good position i have much
really smart people that get to worry
about the nitty-gritty of that uh andrew
barry chris cooper
so i get to sit back and and watch those
guys operate
uh right now they're they're in season
i'm off season
well you know one of the realities of
what's coming and there's a wide
expectation that
players will be cut as teams try to get
under the salary cap
free agents may not get the offers
they're looking for it creates for some
teams an
opportunity to maybe get a better value
dollar for dollar by going with
someone from another team versus a guy
that you
have how comfortable are you with that
possibility of maybe
parting ways with a guy you know a guy
you're comfortable with
but there's another player out there
who's quote unquote better
but you could get him given the dynamics
of this crazy market
for a better dollar for dollar value
than the guy you currently have
yeah i think it's a really good question
mike those are the conversations that i
bet are occurring in
all 32 franchises right now and i think
part of it is you know you're team
building you're not just
acquiring assets so you always are
careful uh not to go
too too overboard and and make sure that
you're just
making moves just to make moves and that
that's not andrew's style at all
andrew's got a plan and and together
we've talked about it and you got to be
ready for those type of opportunities
because
to your point they may occur in this
environment
but we won't do anything that's not well
thought out how much does andrew barry
the gm of the team
accept and listen to your input about
players that
that you want personally that you would
like to have on the team for whatever
reason fits the scheme
good leader fresh legs whatever it may
be how much
does what you want get factored into the
decision making yeah we have a great
dialogue mike uh throughout the season
in the offseason now as we're watching
college players
you know he's watched all these guys i'm
catching up to him so he'll tell me
about it
to go watch a player but he'll make sure
not to to lead me on whether he's good
or bad and then i'll circle back with
him and
and we see things very similarly we also
uh you know
last year sat down and hashed out what
we want this team to look like so
i'm extremely comfortable in andrew
picking the players he's really good at
it
uh and and he listens he's a great
listener both to me
to the coaching staff to the personnel
staff so he does a great job of being
collaborative but ultimately
i trust him to make these decisions and
i think organizationally we trust him to
make these decisions
i know when you had a press conference
yesterday you were asked about jj watt
and you prefer not to talk about
individual players but let me ask you
this my niece
huge browns fan and she got all bent out
of shape about the possibility of j.j
watt joining the browns and she was
excited i said look
whether he signs or not the fact that
the browns are in the conversation
in and of itself is huge because
five years ago you're not in the
conversation do you take any
pride do you take any positivity out of
the fact that it came out
that a guy like jj watt is seriously
considering joining your team
no not in taking pride in that uh per se
mike i'd tell you
when it comes to free agency you do want
to be a destination that guys want to go
to
uh and i think that's a multitude of of
reasons and and
whether it's you're talking about the
city the ownership
uh the coaching staff the players that
he's playing with
the scheme that they're playing in all
of that uh is
is comes in total when you're talking
about the desire of
a free agent to go somewhere but we'd
always prefer to be on those
destinations that guys
want to check out how closely will you
evaluate the quarterbacks
entering this year's draft yeah quite a
bit i think
it's important to know as much as you
can
about a bunch of different positions now
i'm
i'd be lying if i told you i'm gonna
know everything there is to know about
all these guys we got
i have uh andrew berry for that but i do
want to know
about the the signal callers because
because it's important to have some
institutional
knowledge of them uh but we also need to
make sure at least i need to make sure
that i'm
you know appropriating my time to to a
bunch of other positions so
it's not like the old days as a
quarterback coach where you know
everything there is to know about just
that one position i need to know
a lot about multiple positions is it
from a
competitive standpoint and an
institutional knowledge standpoint is it
about
knowing what you can about the guy
because depending upon how the dominoes
may fall someday you could have a chance
to get him or
is it we're going to be playing him so
the more we know about him now
the better suited we're going to be to
prepare to face him later it's
definitely
you know this guy if he's not on our
team he's going to be on somebody's team
that you may be playing so you want to
know their strengths and their
weaknesses as best you can
jared goff carson wentz guys who got big
contracts after three years in the nfl
after five years in the nfl both are
going to be traded officially on march
17 unless
in theory the deals fall through how
much of that is a cautionary tale
for teams that you know hypothetically
have a first round quarterback who's got
three years in and may or may not be
getting a new contract
yeah i think you always want to take in
all the information you can and i know
that's fresh
on them on the minds of everybody
because you know as as fans and as
followers of this league you see that
happening but
you know we take in all the information
from many years
of experience doing this to to inform
our decisions and
and try to not make any decisions based
on the immediacy of what's going on
uh right then and there what do you do
now at this stage of the off season as
it relates to
your preparation for next year whether
it's working on the playbook
evaluating personnel what is it you do
when you show up at the facility
until when you go home yeah i think
you kind of cut your day in half mike so
uh
you know for us we start with scheme
evaluation in the morning and i think
that's such a
big part of what we do in this off
season is pulling apart
ourselves and learning about ourselves
and honestly that's
some of the most fun i've had as a coach
are off seasons off-seasons
and the moment that we're in right now
where you sit together together with
your staff
you put on a ton of tape and you watch
it in order and it's amazing
how it's hard in season to see the
forest through the trees
and then in the off season when you put
it all together and there's no
deadline of hey we got a game coming up
on this sunday you can spend time with
it
we learn a ton about ourselves and
that's what we're doing right now
that process will wrap up in the next
couple weeks but
in terms of how do we get better i think
that's one way we need to
we need to uh tinker uh with what we're
doing i'm not saying we have to have
wholesale
changes to what we're doing offensively
defensively special teams but
we absolutely gotta find new ways of
doing things that that can maximize
our players ability and and that's what
we do in the morning
and then in the afternoon i put my scout
hat on and i put the college tape on and
i try and catch up with andrew barry
and knowing some of these players and
and i don't follow the college game uh
at all really in the during the the fall
so for me
the i don't know much about these guys
it's really a clean slate so i'm
it's an unbiased opinion uh when i'm
watching this tape
speaking to the morning part of your
routine this time of year how dangerous
is it to get caught up in an echo
chamber
when you're looking back at last year
seeing things that you missed
as it was unfolding and thinking wow hey
okay
we got that solved we're going to be a
lot better oh look at this oh wow we're
going to be a lot better we're going to
be better we're going to be better we're
going to be better
and it seems like it's just a breeding
ground for confidence
and it's good to have confidence but it
seems like that's a way that confidence
can maybe get out of control
yeah i think you just got to be so
truthful uh with
with what's on the tape and truthful
with uh you know as i look at it be
honest with myself and with the coaches
i think what it goes back to mike
is alright what are we good at and can
we hang our hat on that well let's let's
keep doing that let's keep teaching it
let's hang our hat on it let's
protect it with this run scheme or
protect it with this pass let's do it
out of this formation
and then something else maybe we're not
so good at it can we coach it better
what what are we missing what's the
coaching point that we're not doing a
good job
if the answer is we can do it better
we're going to try we're going to
install it we're going to
make sure the players understand if the
answer is like i don't know if it fits
us
throw it out there's plenty of offense
there's plenty of defense that we can
get to but
to your point yeah it is something that
i'm very
aware of as as we go through this
process but i think brutal honesty
uh should be a way to to navigate those
concerns
well your morning shift is over you can
check the box on your schedule for today
1 p.m eastern answer stupid questions
for 20 minutes
and now you can go to your afternoon
routine coach congratulations on the
award from last year and the success of
the team all the best in the off season
we look forward to talking again soon
thanks mike i appreciate it hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports